chose en tout cas qui sera intéressant
de considérer c'est avec quelle force là
l'union européenne pourra effectivement
s'occuper et mettre en place une
politique d'asile d'accueil et
d'immigration général ne faut pas
oublier que frontex qui est actuellement
le lagence qui s'occupe justement des
bons partis delà du sujet de la
migration n'a pas des grands moyens
donc je pense que quand il ya des
urgences comme à celle de l'île de
lesbos ou celle de l'île de lampedusa ou
encore des ceuta et mellila en espagne
il n'y a que la force nationale la force
publique nationale de chaque pays qui à
mesure de mettre un peu en limite à 7 à
cette vague migratoire